[Music]
hello i'm johnny knoxville welcome to
jackie we're on the paramount back lot
filming the opening sequence of jackass
forever
we brought in a number of new cast
members i want to say my name all right
this is zach i'm jasper and this is body
surf your mother
this is my first movie
it was really great to be invited to the
crew and everything what'd you think
when you got the call to come in and sit
down with us first thought was hopefully
i don't die then i was like hey at least
i'll die on camera
how you doing over there rachel we man
go into space
they made me laugh so hard and i'm
literally seeing childhood heroes of
mine like come to life
grandpa are you okay my mind is blown
i'm eric i'm from south london i love
skating and i love getting a bit hurt
you get knocked down i'm poopies
big time movie star
my friend tripp goes hey i want to
introduce you to a couple of my friends
i want you to come test out for jackass
[Applause]
and i was like no way like speechless at
that moment the texas rat snake venomous
[Applause]
but you love snakes no i don't you don't
love snakes no
i was pretty nervous getting brought
into this movie honestly because i'm
doing like crazy stuff with all these
people that i've looked up to my entire
life
those guys are getting old we paid our
dues so we're handing the torch to you
i love this dude the new people that
we're working with are great and we've
been destroying them throughout this
film
did you guys feel like you had to earn
it with the guys
for sure
i was so nervous but yeah it was a dream
come true that's the best part it's like
yeah i'm afraid of doing this
[Music]
but it's gonna look awesome
oh
we'll meet again
don't know where
don't know when
but i know we'll meet again
some sunny day
hello i'm johnny knoxville welcome to
jackie
three
two
one
a lot of people ask what will jackass be
like once we're older well it'll get
more mature
the faster you pedal your bike the
faster the other guy's hand goes back
you said it wasn't gonna feel like
anything concussions aren't great but as
long as you have them before you're 50
it's cool and knoxville is 49
so we're good
[Music]
[Applause]
today we're going to do a little
furniture shopping
i've been watching jackass since i was
12 years old
and guess what we're here
[Applause]
we have winners and we have steve
a bunch of nasa scientists right
what did you guys do to eric
fail to prepare prepare to fail
you still got those million dollar teeth
that's for sure
gee didn't set myself up for failure on
this one erin please relax i'm trapped
and you're putting honey on me and
salmon
oh my god
my gosh
[Music]
you